hey guys this is andrew for
troddencensus.com so for those who don't
know me yet let me quickly introduce
myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and i've decided
a few months ago
to create my youtube channel because
guys i want to show you how pro traders
are
working all the different tools and
techniques that we use to make money on
the markets
and actually you're gonna see that most
of our job is to analyze
data so that we can read the flows and
build up a view before taking a position
so in this video i want to show you how
to compute the synthetic short interest
on amc because this is a very useful
data
that you can use to build up your view
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys i've done a video about
the synthetic short already but in this
one i want to make things
perfect i don't want to make any
approximation i want to show
you the exact synthetic short interest
as a percentage of the market cap and in
billion usd notional
so first thing i want to explain to you
how
to compute a synthetic short so i just
wrote the formula here
so the synthetic short which is
basically the position that
hedge funds and market makers have
against
the retail that is buying coal options
when the retail is buying a collapsions
they have a long position
this long position is actually against a
hedge fund or market maker that has the
short position
and we know what are the total number of
call options in the market
and we know that they are all detained
by retail investors
because this is how it works from that
deduce
the synthetic short that is left to
those professionals the formula is here
so it's equal
to the delta so the delta is the
exposure of
each call option if the call is out of
the money
the delta is close to zero i mean if
it's very out of the money
and if it's very deep in the money so if
we are
much above the strike price then the
delta is close to one
so i'm going to show you how to compute
the delta which is kind of difficult
part of this exercise the open interest
you can have it on yahoo finance i'm
going to show you very quickly how
and you for each strike you do delta
time stop open interest times hundred
because it's
the multiplier that is working on all
u.s
options times the spot to get a notional
and you sum this for all the strikes
that are available on the market
here is the data so you go on yahoo
finance
you type amc gamestop tesla
whatever here you're gonna have all the
different maturities
the most liquid ones are the short
maturities you know this is how it works
up to six months roughly and one month
and three months are the most liquid
ones
so i'm gonna keep updating you guys with
with all this data
because you need to update this on a
regular basis to
have the good data all the time and
you just take the database here so you
can copy paste if you want to do it
yourself you have the strike here
the volatility that is here and the open
interest which is the very
interesting part that is in this column
then what i did
guys is that i took all this data and
look
i did it maturity by maturity i did all
of them i did 30s of april
7th of may 14th of may and i went to
july
so i did all of them and then i used my
formula and i sum it up so let's go to
the formula once again together
the only missing part that you have here
is the delta and the delta is this
formula
so you can find it on the internet
everywhere delta is equal
to n of d1 n is the normal distribution
and d1
is this formula that you can come up
with if you know the strike
the spot price the volatility that is
very important that i have here
and the maturity the maturity is in
years so for example for one year is one
for half a year
it's zero five it's not in days if you
guys want to do it at home
then you just sum it up for every strike
and then you do the sum of the total
shot interest and you can see that i did
the chart here
so this chart is just showing me the
distribution of the total
short exposure and you can see that you
have
a concentration around the money around
the 10 level strike
and you have some corruptions and before
the strike which is showing that we have
some
upside gamma on the stock so now
i just sum everything here so i come up
with 250 million
usd and i divide this by the market cap
which is just the total number of shares
outstanding
times the spot price and you can see
that for
anc the total synthetic short and this
is the exact
data is 5.7 exactly
now if amc goes to 20 how this is moving
let's see guys let's check it out it's
going to 12
so this is what we call a gamma it's the
move
of the synthetic short or the move of
the delta
associated to a move of the underlying a
move of spot
and we have some gamma around the 10
level strike as you can see here
the gamma is represented by the
positions that you have at every strike
and you can see that here you don't have
any gamma so then from 20 to 30
it won't move a lot you see it only goes
from 12 to 14
10.5 all right so it's because between
20 and 40 you don't have much
gamma now let me show you how this
is looking for apple for apple i did
the exact same thing so this is the
shape it has so you can see
that you don't have any upside gamma on
those stocks
because they are just not moving the
same way
and the volatility is much lower it's
around 50
and you can see that the total synthetic
short for normal stock
like apple a big tech company is around
40 beeps 0.4 and how this is moving in
the upside
it's not moving a lot you know it's like
always below
one percent all right guys this is what
i wanted to show
you here so most importantly guys just
keep in mind that the synthetic short
for amc is six percent just quickly for
gamestop guys it has
this shape i'm gonna do a video very
soon where i'm gonna
give you more information about what
might happen around this level if we go
there
but the shape is completely different
and for apple it's like this
so amc is between you know a normal
stock and a crazy stock like gamestop
only talking about the distribution of
the open interest call options
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and
i hope i managed to explain to you how
to compute this data that is very
interesting to use
to take your positions and if you like
that please don't forget to click on the
sub
like and button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys